die heute-show
WM bedingt etwas später als sonst aber
über die WM reden wir ja nicht mehr ne
welche WM überhaupt kann sich hier noch
einer die WM erinnern ich nicht
freuen wir uns lieber meine Damen und
Herren über das Wenige was noch gute
Laune macht zum Beispiel über die erste
postcode Adventszeit über
Weihnachtsmärkte fast ohne Beschränkung
endlich gilt wieder eins unserer
wichtigsten Grundrechte überhaupt man
darf die neuen Glühwein und die sieben
Reibekuchen wieder direkt vor die Bude
mit dem Tennis aus dem Erzgebirge Reihe
Tradition ist so wichtig meine Damen und
Herren
mal diese Weihnachten leider nein liebe
Zuschauer zu Hause bitte halten Sie
Ihren Kindern jetzt die Ohren zu das
herrscht Fachkräftemangel 50
Weihnachtsmänner wollten kommen 12 sind
nur da wir haben leider viele alte
Weihnachtsmänner verloren durch
Krankheit durch Alter durch Tod
leider
apropos den Christkind ist auch ab hier
eine Bild
und aus den Rentieren habe ich Buletten
gemacht ja
verdammte Fachkräftemangel in diesem
Land
Fachkräftemangel selbst die
Weihnachtsmänner gehen uns aus aber
keine Angst dafür holen wir jetzt
qualifizierte Leute aus dem Ausland
haben sie bestimmt gelesen die Ampel
arbeitet an einem hochmodernen
Einwanderungsrecht und der Kanzler
persönlich erklärt den neuen Mitbürgern
was deutsch sein ausmacht und zum Glück
gibt es Traditionen die uns verbinden
und auf ganz eigene Weise führt
Zusammengehörigkeit sorgen
dazu gehört dass wir Weihnachtsbäume
aufstellen
ja
ist Außenstehenden schwer zu erklären
aber wir haken tatsächlich Bäume ab
stellen sie ins Wohnzimmer stellen echte
Kerzen drauf und werden am Schluss von
der Feuerwehr evakuiert das
schafft in Deutschland
Zusammengehörigkeit
die Ampel hat neue Ideen zum Thema
Staatsbürgerschaft so könnten zum
Beispiel hier lebende Ausländer schon
nach fünf statt nach acht Jahren
deutsche werden und das kam riesig an
vor allem bei der Union und bei
Friedrich Merz persönlich zumal
zumal die Regierung ja auch noch das
Aufenthaltsrecht großzügiger gestalten
will worauf März hier sinngemäß sagt
lassen wir mal die Tassen im Schrank
genau
beziehungsweise die Ausländer im Ausland
gut dazu muss man wissen die neue CDU
hat sich einen Vorsitzenden direkt aus
den 90er Jahren geholt und der redet
dann halt auch so
erregt sich zum Beispiel furchtbar auf
er regt sich wahnsinnig auf weil die
Ampel die doppelte Staatsbürgerschaft
theoretisch für jeden ermöglichen will
so wie das übrigens fast überall in
Europa läuft kann man gar nicht
vergleichen das sind halt irgendwelche
Staatsbürgerschaften wir reden hier über
die deutsche die deutsche
Staatsbürgerschaft ist etwas sehr
wertvolles und damit muss man behutsam
umgehen was wir vermeiden müssen ist
Einwanderung in die Sozialsysteme und
wenn das das Ziel der Koalition ist dann
werden wir dem natürlich nicht zustimmen
natürlich und das liebe Kinder nennt man
framing denn der Onkel Fritz hier weiß
ganz genau dass es bei der
Staatsbürgerschaft eben nicht um
Einwanderung in Sozialsysteme geht
eingebürgert wird hier wer den
Lebensunterhalt für sich und seine
Familie nachweislich beschreiben kann
ohne Sozialhilfe verstehen sie die
nehmen nichts raus aus der Kasse die
Zahlen was ein ja es ist reine
Stimmungsmache wirklich
ja Stimmungsmache überlegen Sie mal fast
alle wichtigen Wirtschaftsverbände loben
die Pläne der Ampel und ich sag mal bei
dem Fachkräftemangel wir sprachen schon
über Weihnachtsmänner macht es durchaus
Sinn Leute die sowieso hier sind Steuern
zahlen und Deutsch können dass man den
den Pass gibt ja in Einzelfällen bald
sogar schon vielleicht nach drei Jahren
für besondere Integrationsleistung dafür
plant die Ampel wohl eine Prüfung in der
Ausländerbehörde wo die Bewerber
nachweisen die deutschen inzwischen sind
die müssen z.B wissen was ein Faxgerät
ist und wie man das bedient die sollen
instinktiv drauf haben was man als
Deutscher in Notsituation als erstes
macht richtig
Massen von Klopapier aufkaufen
echte neugermanen müssen ihr
Rhythmusgefühl verlieren und ab jetzt
wahnsinnig schlecht tanzen und für den
Arbeitsalltag beherrschen sie die
lustigsten deutschen bürosprüche
Tür mit ö
tschau mit v
bis bald
Bundesgartenschau
herzlichen Glückwunsch ja übrigens
ebenfalls prüfungsrelevant Sandalen
trägt man hier nur mit tennison aber das
ist glaube ich bekannt meine man soll
nicht schön reden klar gibt's bei uns
Parallelgesellschaften wo man sich
abschottet und kaum Interesse hat
vernünftig Deutsch zu lernen und das
betrifft nicht nur Bayern
ja das betrifft auch migrantische
Communitys ja die aktuellen
Flüchtlingszahlen bringen unsere
Kommunen ihre Grenze das ist so aber das
ist halt ein völlig anderes Thema auch
wichtig aber ein anderes Thema wir
müssen es irgendwie schaffen
mehrfachkräfte hierhin zu locken und
zwar eben nicht nur IT-Leute oder Ärzte
über die sie in der Union am liebsten
reden sondern alle möglichen Berufe alle
möglichen in einem internationalen
Ranking in einem Ranking der
beliebtesten Einwanderungsländer liegt
Deutschland beim Thema sich zu Hause
fühlen nur auf Platz 56 von 64
bei Freundlichkeit der Bewohner auf 57
vielleicht gehen die deswegen lieber in
andere Länder vielleicht gucken sie aber
auch deutsches Fernsehen und hören was
Unionspolitiker so labern die deutsche
Staatsbürgerschaft ist auch ein Wert an
sich es ist nicht was es zum Nulltarif
geben kann der deutsche Pass darf nicht
zu am Schwager werden und gleich
ausgehändigt werden nach so kurzer Zeit
ja wir drängen den jedem auf der nicht
bei drei auf dem Baum ist ich sehe das
oft hier in Köln ne japanische Touristen
fotografieren in Ruhe den Kölner Dom und
dann ne schmeißt man den deutschen Pass
an Kopf die wollen eine für zwei maximal
drei Tage bleiben aber unser Staat
zwingt die deutsche zu werden die werden
gezwungen
schlimm meine umgekehrt wird doch ein
Schuh draus wir müssen uns anstrengen
damit mehr qualifizierte Leute hier hin
wollen
Visa Verfahren im Ausland dauern auch
für
gute Bewertung oder ja wie gesagt wir
fahren im Ausland dauern auch für top
ausgebildete Fachkräfte auf jahrelang
weil die entsprechenden deutschen
Behörden chronisch untergesetzt sind
die große Frage liebe Zuschauer was ist
eigentlich Deutsch also außer immer
schon in der Vorrunde rausfliegen
wir haben heute einen mit Trikot im
Publikum ich weiß gar nicht mehr
ich weiß nicht warum
jetzt erst recht sehr gut sehr gut ja
was ist deutsch ne wann gehört man hier
wirklich dazu zum wir und ist bei
manchen die Vorfreude auf Deutschland
möglicherweise übertrieben Dietmar
Wischmeyer klärt schonungslos auf
Dietmar Wischmeyer ist
der einwanderungscoach
Liebe Fachkräfte aus aller Welt schön
dass ihr nach Deutschland wollt ist auf
jeden Fall interessante Erfahrung nur
eins vorab damit er nicht enttäuscht
seid Perfektion Pünktlichkeit die lange
Unterhose auf DIN A4 gefaltet dieses
Deutschland war einmal wir haben uns
verändert das Land das euch vorschwebt
gibt es nur noch in schmierigen
Werbefilmen wie dem hier weg Germany's
Minister für economy Gefährts Germany
ist er country bei wer's plenty
happening right now man was hier alles
happens das glaubt ihr gar nicht blonde
Frauen mit eigenem Tablet andere Filmen
den Löwenzahn beim anwachsen und nicht
weiter vor dem trauten Tal wacht der
Herrgott über die deutsche Heimat
arglistige Täuschung da denkst du das
ist Deutschland und dann steigst den
Herne aus dem Bus ja vielen Dank auch
die Realität sieht doch so aus nicht mal
mehr die Deutsche Post arbeitet noch
nach Plan zwar soll sie laut Gesetz 80%
der Briefe am nächsten Tag zustellen
aber aber es ist so wie immer sie kommen
gar nicht auch Rentner Volker ist nur
noch sauer ich habe die Schnauze voll
bitte mitschreiben ich habe die Schnauze
voll ist einer der wichtigsten Sätze im
deutschen Alltag Menschen die in gelben
Autos rumfahren und Briefe verteilen das
ist doch einerseits oldschool
andererseits die einzige
Kommunikationsform die unsere Behörden
kennen alles andere kann dauern ein
konkretes Datum von ihnen kriege ich
heute nicht wann ich den Perso online
beantragen kann das möchte ich nicht so
laut sagen weil ich ja die Abläufe kenne
in Deutschland ja weil er machen er ist
ja nur Bundeskanzler
Digitalisierung made in Germany da
staunt die ausländische Fachkraft und
steigt in den nächsten Zug nach Kanada
jetzt die schlechte Nachricht Züge
fahren ja gar nicht mehr aus sein
haarwerksvideo wo mehrkornbrötchen von
absurd gut gelaunten Verkäuferinnen
gereicht werden und dann kommt die
Frechheit schlechthin ein deutscher
Bahnhof und dazu das Wort
Verlässlichkeit das muss man sich
erstmal trauen ja ja Werbung lügt ich
weiß aber es gibt doch Grenzen
coming to Germany to bring me the skills
yes and maybe you fancy Autobahn will
you can Bretter es fast
wegen Baustelle oh wie Heft aber
Mülltrennung in Internet in Mode citys
exceauce Gold Funklöcher in diesem Sinne
schön dass ihr trotzdem kommen wollt
übrigens hatte ich schon erwähnt wer
Deutscher wird hat auf einen Schlag
knapp 30.000 Euro Staatschulden und
zahlt meine fette boomerente
ach ihr macht das schon wenn was ist
ich bin auf Teneriffa
dietmarieschmeyer ist
der einwanderungscoach
dafür endet diese Woche endlich die
Gaskrise
Qatar liefert uns Flüssiggas
okay nur drei Prozent unseres
Jahresbedarfs und erst ab Moment 2026
obwohl wir es vor allem in den nächsten
beiden Wintern brauchen aber immerhin
und wem verdanken wir das richtig Robert
Habeck ja
da waren die Rückenschmerzen nach seinem
Katar besucht doch wenigstens nicht ganz
umsonst sage ich mal und dann nächste
Top-Nachricht ist der Gesetzentwurf für
die Strom- und gaspreisbremse endlich
Papier geworden sogar 161 seitenpapier
was drauf steht verstehen allerdings die
wenigsten und jetzt wird's etwas
kompliziert für viele wahrscheinlich so
ein bisschen kompliziert man aber
vielleicht liegt es einfach auch daran
dass es wirklich kompliziert ist dadurch
wird es hier kompliziert zu kompliziert
für alle anderen wird es komplizierter
und deswegen ist es nicht ganz
unkompliziert
es ist komplizierter als die Länder
Punkte damals bei Tutti Frutti wirklich
ich habe es versucht zu lesen es geht
nicht ja eine mit der ganz heißen Nadel
gestrickte energiepreisbremse dabei war
doch seit Februar klar was mit den
Energiepreisen passiert unterlassen die
erst jetzt im Dezember über ein Gesetz
abstimmen das schon ab Januar greifen
soll das erinnert mich als Fahrschüler
sehr stark an Hausaufgaben im Bus machen
meine Damen und Herren auf den
allerletzten Drucker kennen wir noch so
die einen mehr kann jetzt über ein
Bürokratiemonster die anderen freuen
sich über pure Poesie Liebe
Kulturfreunde
ich lese nun einen Auszug aus Robert
habecks Lyrikband die Strom- und
gaspreisbremse
nach Nummer eins Buchstabe a
Doppelbuchstabe AA müssen die
Elektrizitätsversorgungsunternehmen
unverzüglich Bilanzkreis scharf die
anletzt Verbraucher über das Netz
gelieferte strohmmenge mitteilen für die
eine Entlastung in Anspruch genommen
werden kann weil für sie ein
Arbeitskreis oberhalb der Referenzpreise
nach Paragraph 5 Absatz 2 Satz 1
vereinbart ist
bis dann danke schön
keine Ahnung wie sieht das Empfinden
aber für mich auf Augenhöhe mit den
Buddenbrooks
jedenfalls als Einschlafhilfe die Ampel
will den Paragraphen Pornos von dem wir
gerade Auszüge gehört haben bis zum 16
Dezember durch den Bundesrat Peitschen
wobei ist das schon noch ein paar offene
Fragen gibt verstößt das Ganze zum
Beispiel doch gegen Eigentumsrecht ist
es okay verschiedene Energieträger
unterschiedlich zu subventionieren
Gasstrom und Fernwärme werden gefördert
Öl und pelletheizer gucken in die Röhre
aber das machen
heiße Nadel Halt und die Zeit drängt
Freunde mehr als ein Drittel der
Deutschen machen sich inzwischen Sorgen
ob sie die Energierechnung noch bezahlen
können nur einer ist total optimistisch
aber die Menschen teilweise in diesem
Land haben meine Sachen zumindest
zurecht Sorge wie sie ihre Nebenkosten
wie Sie Ihre Heizkosten alles
gut Moment
also nach Uli Hoene steuerverständnis
zahlt der Stadt wirklich alles ne
ja man muss dazu sagen rTL hatte als
Steuerexperten ursprünglich Alfons
Schuhbeck eingeladen aber
der konnte irgendwie nicht ja so ganz
wichtig zu dem was der Höhn ist gerade
gesagt hat trotz Deckel ist der Strom
immer noch viel teurer als vorher
teilweise doppelt so teuer man könnte
sogar sagen der Deckel ist sowas wie ja
wie eine optische Täuschung
die Preise
gucken sie da nicht hin die
die Preise werden in Wirklichkeit nicht
gesenkt die werden versteckt außerdem
rettet uns auch nicht der Staat sondern
wir uns selber das geschenkte Geld
bezahlen wir über Schuldendienst Abgaben
oder Steuern sonst so oder ja es hilft
wohl nichts meine Damen und Herren
wahrscheinlich muss man sich doch von
den krassesten Stromfressern
verabschieden trennen ja ich z.B
von meinem geliebten 1000 Watt
Sandwichmaker
nach all den Jahren so vieles Sandwiches
so viele Erinnerungen die romantischen
Abende zu zweit die gemeinsam Urlaube
wir haben uns gegenseitig eingecremt
waren unzertrennlich alles vorbei mach's
gut alter Freund
Energie Spaß so
apropos traurig Österreich deckelt den
Strom auf 10 Cent wir auf 40 das ist für
Stromanbieter wie eine Einladung zum
Abkassieren
Verbraucherschützer waren ausdrücklich
vor sogenannten Mitnahmeeffekten ist
irgendjemand überrascht ja und wenn sie
zu Hause jetzt denken Moment um sowas zu
verhindern haben wir doch das Kartellamt
muss ich Sie leider enttäuschen das Amt
stellt man sich ja so vor wie eine Tasse
Finanzpolizei die bei gierigen Konzernen
die Tür Eintritt und dann aber so
richtig aufräumen in dem Laden äh kurz
zurück Wirklichkeit da sitzt einer im
Kartell am vorm Rechner und beobachtet
die Branche mit anderen Worten der guckt
CHECK24
und sieht was der Strompreis gerade
macht ja viel Erfolg beim Beobachten
allein in Deutschland gibt es über 1000
Stromanbieter mit lauter
unterschiedlichen Tarifen um die Preise
Explosion zu verstehen müsste man aber
erstmal das sogenannte married
order-prinzip erklären
bei der Anstalt würden Sie jetzt eine
von ihren Tafeln reinziehen Moment da
fällt mir ein wir haben hier im ZDF
dieses Austauschprogramm ja wirklich
zdf-shows sind verpflichtet sich
gegenseitig zu helfen Klaus von Wagner
soll sofort mit der Tafel reinkommen
[Applaus]
vielen Dank auch gell ich war gerade mit
meiner Frau Essen verdammtes
Austauschprogramm ist super schön Klaus
dass du kommen musst ist wirklich voll
nett ich komme dann auch mal zu euch in
die anstatt oh Gott ja ja ja wir rufen
dich dann an okay aber jetzt im Ernst
wenn wir das hier machen dann bestehe
darauf dass wir dann auch mal ein
bisschen in die Tiefe gehen in deiner
blöden Show das ist ein hochkomplexes
Thema ja klar Tiefe machen wir auch oft
genau also Merrit order und ich werde
garantiert nicht unterbrochen also von
irgendwelchen kurzen lustigen Politiker
Clips ja kann mich 100% drauf verlassen
nein
also mache ich hier eigentlich okay
bring was hinter uns Meret order
beschreibt die Preisbildung auf Märkten
ja die verschiedenen Energieträger
produzieren Strom zu sehr
unterschiedlichen Kosten das kann man
hier sehen hier erneuerbare Wind Strom
billig ne dann kommt atombraun Kohle
Steinkohle teurer gasauteuer und jetzt
wird's spannend
Pass überhaupt auf ja klar klar kommt
nur gerade eine Meldung zum
brasilienspiel im Rhein sie haben
Ronaldo verhaftet weil der nackt
also wie entsteht der Strompreis da
bekommt tatsächlich jeder Erzeuger
dasselbe pro Kilowattstunde und dieser
Preis richtet sich nach dem teuersten
also dem Gaspreis vor Putins ein Marsch
war das Okay ja also da hat man wenn man
günstig Strom produziert hat z.B mit
Windrädern nicht da hat man dann ist man
belohnt worden mit Gewinnen aktuell ist
das ganze nur noch Irrsinn gigantische
übergewinne werden produziert wegen Gas
das aber nur 10% unseres Stroms sicher
das ist so als ob eine Dose Hanser Pilze
so viel kostet wie ein Chateau Marco
[Gelächter]
schade in der Anstalt wäre das ein
riesendacher gewesen okay aber
unterschiedliche das passiert mir hier
so oft weißt du wir zeigen dann einfach
irgendwas lustiges
[Applaus]
okay also der Strompreis hängt wie
gesagt derzeit am Gaspreis und jetzt
gibt es folgende simple aber beste Idee
das lassen wir einfach wir hören einfach
damit auf kapiere ich nicht egal
muss man sich jedes Mal eine Tafel
reinziehen
so hier sieht man was passiert wenn man
z.B das Erdgas aus der Preisbildung raus
nimmt indem man z.B den Gaspreis
begrenzt nein dann ist die teuerste den
Preis bestimmte Energie etwa die
Steinkohle ja was passiert der
Strompreis er singt dramatisch dann
erstattet man den Gaskraftwerk Betreiber
ihre Einbußen durch eine Umlage die alle
Stromverbraucher finanzieren und der
Verbraucherpreis landet dann am Ende
trotzdem bei ungefähr 25 Cent pro
Kilowattstunde oder soweit verstanden
ja ja ja
ist gut ist gut und wir bräuchten dann
auch kein komplizierten strompreisdeckel
ja aber Sekunde warum machen wir das
dann nicht in der heute show hätte ich
gesagt weil viele Stromerzeuger von der
Situation profitieren
aber in der Anstalt fragen wir uns was
passiert wenn man das macht ja wenn man
hier Gaspreis Deckel der Strompreis
singt wo ist denn dann der Anreiz
Energie zu sparen vor allem ist die
Industrie wäre es nicht besser die
übergewinne wirklich abzuschöpfen vor
allem bei den fossilen und um zu
verteilen muss Strom überhaupt an Börsen
gehandelt werden und genau dazu habe ich
zufällig noch ein 10 mal 12 Meter große
Tafel vorbereitet die hole ich mal eben
kurz rein weil die habe ich nämlich auf
dem Parkplatz ich finde das toll dass
die Tiefe zulassen ist ist gar nicht ist
gar nicht nötig klar
ja schließt die Tür ab sonst kommt er
wieder rein
so und stehe ich richtig super also dann
los
liebe Fans der feinsten Unterhaltung
klickt hier hin wenn ihr weitere Videos
sehen wollt
das war's super take
wir haben es euch hier auch echt
Schnecke aus heute